[Musica]
li riconoscete questi occhi
Questi sono gli occhi di Totti Pochi
istanti prima di battere il calcio di
rigore contro l'Australia siamo nei
Mondiali del 2006 l'Italia sta giocando
in 10 e in un momento di grande
difficoltà
c'è un rigore all'ultimo minuto
Francesco Totti nella sua biografia
racconta che ha alzato la testa e ha
visto che tutti i suoi compagni c'erano
dileguati non c'era uno che prendesse il
pallone erano divorati dalla tensione
vi sembra un uomo che attenzione mi
sembra un uomo che ha paura
Probabilmente sì perché in quel momento
lui che tornava da un grave infortunio
sapeva che si stava giocando molto della
sua credibilità forse nel momento più
importante della sua carriera forse nel
momento più importante di un gruppo che
era cresciuto con lui un gruppo di amici
non solo di compagni che avevano un
sogno che volevano realizzare il sogno
di compiere a pieno il loro talento e
lui aveva la palla sul dischetto e la
necessità di fare gol era un uomo Teso
la tensione l'abbiamo sentito poco fa
porta anche delle difficoltà fisiche per
un calciatore che sta per battere un
calcio di rigore ci sono degli Studi
fisici proprio gli ormoni che
sviluppiamo comportano delle difficoltà
oggettive cala la vista leggermente i
muscoli si induriscono
cala la percezione della distanza
il portiere sembra più grande la porta
sembra più piccola
la tensione può portarci ad avere
difficoltà nell'esprimere il nostro
talento tutti noi abbiamo un talento il
compito per un genitore riuscire a
capire il talento di un figlio per una
persona e riuscire a capire il proprio
riuscire a capire dove riesce ad
esprimersi al meglio poi per esprimere
il proprio talento abbiamo delle
difficoltà ad affrontare nella vita
alcune sono esterne non hanno nessuna
relazione con noi e noi perdiamo troppo
tempo a starci dietro perché ci sono
delle cose che valgono come il Pi greco
sono numeri dati sono cose che esistono
e cercare di modificarle non porta a
nessun cambiamento positivo e ansia una
perdita di tempo e di energie Eppure la
tensione lì la tensione può chiudere le
nostre idee può impedirci di sviluppare
quello che veramente vorremmo sviluppare
di raggiungere il nostro obiettivo è lì
e dobbiamo cercare non di combatterla
perché io non credo tanto alla teoria
del Gladiatore che combatte contro i
propri sentimenti controllarla
conoscerla
perché la base per riuscire a esprimere
il nostro talento è sempre la conoscenza
Parliamo di sport
immaginate Oltre a un giocatore che sta
per battere un calcio di rigore un
atleta che sta percorrere 100 metri alle
Olimpiadi pensate a Jacobs una vita per
quei dieci secondi li avete mai visti
sui blocchi di partenza guardano il
vuoto lo sapete cosa fanno
visualizzano la gara hanno una visione
di quello che devono fare e se la
visione è positiva gli dà la possibilità
di esprimersi al meglio Ma come fa a
essere positive e credibile perché se mi
metto io e blocchi di partenza posso
avere la visione più bella del mondo ma
sempre ultimo arrivo però ma loro invece
riescono a visualizzare quello che
veramente possono ottenere come sanno
quello che possono ottenere
lo sanno attraverso la conoscenza
sanno delle cose hanno imparato delle
cose hanno studiato delle cose di loro
stessi e del mondo che li circonda
Quindi quando noi abbiamo di fronte un
momento di tensione importante dobbiamo
essere in grado innanzitutto di fare
queste due cose di avere la visione di
quello che stiamo facendo e di quello
che stiamo per fare e cercare di avere
una visione positiva che si concluda
bene che ci porti
Se non al successo Certamente al
miglioramento di noi stessi e di quello
che facciamo e poi dobbiamo avere
i dati
le cognizioni il sapere Quindi quando io
mi avvicino alla telecronaca so che se
la telecronaca è particolarmente
importante come quella ai Mondiali o
agli europei o anche partite decisive o
anche semplicemente partite belle Io lo
so che avrò tensione come cerco di
combatterla questa tensione Prima di
tutto visualizzando quello che devo fare
e poi cercando di sapere tutto perché
Perché
una parte di quello che ci circonda non
lo possiamo controllare ma l'altra parte
Sì l'altra parte dipende da noi dal
nostro impegno da quello che facciamo
da quello che riusciamo a sviluppare dal
modo in cui riusciamo a tirare fuori il
meglio dal nostro talento si parla molto
spesso a sproposito del talento si dice
che le persone di talento hanno successo
nella vita le persone di talento hanno
una possibilità di avere successo nella
vita ma tutti noi siamo persone di
talento ognuno di voi Ognuno di noi ha
un talento particolare per qualcosa
dobbiamo conoscerlo e dobbiamo
annaffiarlo tutti i giorni perché
altrimenti la piantina del nostro
talento non diventerà mai Un bell'albero
diventerà qualcosa di stortignaccolo che
non punterà mai al sole che non riuscirà
a raggiungere veramente la luce se noi
non ci lavoriamo quotidianamente come
dobbiamo fare
E cosa ci dà la conoscenza la conoscenza
ci dà anche la possibilità di cambiare
magari nel corso della nostra vita la
visione e qui Mi rivolgo soprattutto a
quelli più giovani di voi questo vuol
dire anche avere coraggio nella vita
perché quando sapete le cose e avete
scelto le fonti un elemento fondamentale
nella vita del 2022 capire quali sono le
fonti giuste per avere le informazioni
giuste una volta che voi avete le fonti
giuste avete le cognizioni giuste potete
avere il coraggio di scendere dalla
collina dove siamo tutti e salire nella
collina accanto quella che ti dà un
punto di vista diverso un orizzonte
diverso e avere il coraggio di accettare
gli altri che mentre scendi ti dicono ma
dove vai e da qua che si vede ma tu sai
perché conosci te stesso e il mondo che
ti circonda che c'è una possibilità
diversa la possibilità di vedere le cose
da un altro punto di vista che magari
diventerà vincente se ancora non lo è in
questo momento
e quindi vedere e conoscere sono la
stessa cosa ma anche questo non può
bastare
perché ce la quotidianità e c'è
soprattutto la differenza tra pensare le
cose e farle si chiama esecuzione
eseguire bene cercare
di fare le cose per il meglio e come si
fa questo li si prova vi porto un altro
esempio andare a Pirlo qualcuno di voi
avrà sentito conoscerà chi segue il
calcio il calcio di punizione di andare
a Pirlo la maledetta una cosa
assolutamente innovativa calciava il
pallone come non aveva mai calciato
nessuno aveva avuto una visione diversa
e questo l'ha portato a segnare più gol
di tutti gli altri su calcio di
punizione del campionato italiano ma
racconta lui che non è che è arrivato un
giorno in un famoso Milan - Juventus ha
battuto il calcio di punizione ha fatto
gol così no ha visto come lui doveva
battere il calcio di punizioni lo ha
pensato poi è andato a Milanello ha
battuto 100 1000 10.000 calci di
punizione lui stesso racconta che i
primi finivano fuori dallo stadio fuori
dal campo di allenamento che i
magazziniere lo odiavano perché dovevano
andare in giro per il bosco intorno a
Milano andare a recuperare il pallone
poi un giorno ha incominciato a
inquadrare la porta una volta su 10
poi una volta su 5 poi 5 su 10 poi 9 su
10 e magari due volte su 10 riusciva
anche a trovare l'incrocio dei pali o la
palla bassa e riusciva a fare gol e
seguiva nel giusto modo approvato a
eseguire nel giusto modo se Voi
riuscirete come ho cercato di fare io Ma
come dobbiamo cercare di fare tutti a
utilizzare questi piccoli semplici
strumenti per vincere la tensione Allora
possiamo stare tranquilli che la
tensione si trasformerà non sarà più
qualcosa che ci impedirà di sviluppare
il nostro talento Ma sarà semplicemente
un campanello d'allarme che ti sta
dicendo Ehi quello che stai per fare è
una cosa importante per te e per chi ti
è intorno e quando una cosa importante
bisogna agire in maniera conseguente
bisogna cercare di vedere le cose
nel modo giusto nella maniera corretta
bisogna cercare di avere tutti gli
strumenti necessari per apprendere le
cose che ci servono nella maniera giusta
scegliendo le fonti giuste sempre nella
maniera corretta e poi una volta che ci
siamo creati questo background ci sarà
la possibilità con il lavoro con la
pazienza
di eseguire nella maniera corretta
questo vi porterà al successo ci porterà
al successo ci porterà Totti al successo
qualcun altro al successo questo non lo
potete sapere Non lo può sapere nessuno
perché è successo dipende da tante altre
cose e molte di queste sono proprio
esterne arrivano da fuori e sono fuori
dal nostro controllo però vi posso dire
una cosa sicuramente avrete più
probabilità di raggiungerlo Perché
lavorando in questo modo su voi stessi
avrete la possibilità ogni giorno di
alzarvi e lavorare su quello che vedo
intorno e su voi stessi per cercare di
migliorare un po' di crescere un po' di
fare un piccolo passo in avanti e questa
è una cosa che non mi deve Mai
abbandonare qualsiasi sia la vostra età
perché ricordate che se vi alzerete un
giorno senza il pensiero di migliorarvi
di sapere una cosa in più di nutrire la
vostra curiosità di lavorare col cesello
per eseguire un po' meglio le cose
in quella mattina voi finirete di vivere
e la vita comincerà a vivere voi Grazie
buonasera